the Joe Rogan experience what is the
difference like when when Thai fighters
come over there what what gets in their
way like what well that's the times
they're very technical and what that
brings me up to something else but
basically are very technical and they do
very well for the first couple of rounds
but then when the pain threshold starts
to kick in when they started clinch and
then they get ahead but there's no
what's happening here right and that's
that's good that you asked me this if
you look at me amar you know and then
Thailand to neighboring country they
were fighting for thousands of years old
and if you look at back and it is the
tongue to Empire I think I don't know
the exact date but at that time the
Burmese Empire was like all the
Southeast Asia the biggest Empire in
Southeast Asia so they were owning all
of Thailand almost like Chiang Mai all
these things like you know I'm not sure
Vietnam and Laos all these things so it
was very very powerful that's why they
say that literal is the ancestor of all
the muy muy Lao moo cow Muay Thai you
know because it makes sense they were
while they were owning all these
colonies right they were dropping their
seeds of their martial arts so then as
the retreat eventually pushed them away
and they became you know Burma as we as
we go we have another starting a thing
called Muay Boran yeah entirely so then
but then it's very suspicious like how
come you have that sport now with no
gloves and head butts Moran is that yeah
and you know but but you were colonized
for a long time by little by me all
right so then basically their version of
it yeah
and he added big ropes instead of doing
bare knuckle let's wait it was only a
bit of cause they added big ropes right
so then at one point the king of
Thailand did a great thing to attract
tourism which removed the headbutt and
adding a scoring system and added gloves
a town's love and a beautiful intricate
and it becomes beautiful Muay Thai as we
know very very you know technical very
nice but then then what happened is that
if I let's say your Muay Thai guys hey
you have Big Al's a towns love and you
borrow if you punch you don't score a
lot of points you know it's it's it's
elbows and knees and kicks that score
points so what's going to happen over
hundreds of years the guys are going to
practice their kicks and it because I
think the Tigers are the strongest
kickers in the world I believe and yeah
so so then if you go you go across in me
I'm are they by the way guys no gloves
no scoring system and if you if you SK
only to win
swing for the freakin fence right so
that's the two different type of so you
have weightless kicks in inlets way
because you're pretty viralize you
prefer like you know no gloves because
you can draw blood right away with a
punch make sense so yeah it's just a
history course have you thought about
fighting more and more time or maybe
even fighting MMA or do you yeah yeah
but not Muay Thai though and I'm like
nothing I've done it I don't wanna do it
again how come
well I represented its way yeah so you
enjoy it more yes it's freeing you know
like you can do head but there's no love
I don't I don't want to put on like love
dia I would consider maybe I mean I have
offers but one championship and Bellator
okay I was actually with Kong the other
day in San Jose economy fedosya no he's
a legend of martial arts and a-- a
specialist and if he actually called
Scott Coker in front of me is like I get
him a fight
like I said well give me a couple years
I have a lot of things to do that I want
to be happy with my literate career you
know more things to do but it's a
possible do you know 27 27 so you you're
still young I mean you could make that
transition yeah into MMA then wanted to
we can go we can go to this actually
actually fight MMA two times yeah I was
I was so I'm a stupid I was younger so
in that transition before going to
prison fight it sir after president
fight but like in that transition like I
had a year or two before raising enough
money to go back and like I said my
first love was grappling right so I was
doing I did some fight nights amateur
MMA and I was I was when I first MMA
fight by guillotine and then I went the
air again another guillotine so they
gave me like the octopus - joking game
and then third fight was against
GSP prodigy like a Japanese guy so I
went by decision so I was undefeated in
MMA in amateur but then I go I go back
from Thailand I'm super excited I'm
doing my striking and I added some super
decision like nobody wanted to fight the
moon he's a good fighter he's a good
fighter and he was a new journey of see
now what's his name Jonathan Mooney if
what Kobe Kovac in not long ago and so
nobody want to fight him and you know he
was like I you know it's gonna be a
striking [ __ ] easily people saying he
was a great striker so let's go I'm the
best striker so let's do something so
nobody nobody was
except in the fight so I accept the
fight but I think it was a bit early for
my pretty view he was already on the
Raider for UFC right so I took the fight
at 170 but I was 170 so he was a it was
a big boy and I think he dropped down to
like from 190 and but then on the feet
I'm like I'm winning I'm doing some good
spinning keep spinning punches and
everything but then furious is in his
corner and he's like down bring him down
so I just stupid I went on the I went on
the floor and for me I treated it as a
Maratha
BJJ competition so when I'm on the floor
I'm on the floor you know III wasn't
over I wasn't very developed yet I
didn't have the ring experience yet and
again it was the better fighter that
that night for sure I almost had the
armbar actually and I'd let it go and
the referee I virtually stopped the
fight because of elbows and in the
clinch and in the in the guard but I
yeah it was a bit disappointed for this
and so it was just a bad you know
initial in early in my career now I'm a
completely different fighter I fight you
know in front of thousands of people
I've I've have so again he's a great
fighter but I know that I would it would
be a different thing it is crazy that
you you became this let weight champion
without really training that way like
you didn't really go to a traditional
that way gym or learn it from them you
basically had your own approach thing
together yeah yeah
I think so I think it's like I said
better martial art in my in my in Canada
we we do a lot of like you know sands
and ax and a lot of seneschal and my co
super bad is he did like two two pro
fights but he's a great coach he's a
very great coach and he just build me up
for it because in G kundo he's a seafood
right so you can do there's a lot of in
the in the pocket there's a lot of head
butts actually stuff everything you know
everything goes yeah so yeah I guess
that's why I kind of did everything what
you what do you want to do as far as
your career do you want to establish
some sort of dominance and let way
before you leave and go do something
else
well to be honest the only reason why I
want I would consider go back to MMA
would be because I have ego I think all
fighters have you go and I want to
[ __ ] avenge my loss and stuff like
that so but honestly I'm super happy
with doing this as my my goal was to be
champion now I've done it
only 20 bells to be happy
[Applause]